we've been warned this was coming to
britain's high streets a fish and chip
shop in bradford driven out of business
by the economic squeeze this is the cost
of the cost of living crisis
and it's spreading
another shop in bradford forced to close
the shutters coming down on a place much
loved by customers who simply couldn't
afford it anymore
what ursula sutcliffe started with a
hundred pounds a place of plants coffee
and community now being packed up for
good
people had come out and then changed the
mind they thought that's it so they've
completely changed the habits
and even though people were supporting
you sometimes online or just from a
distance sending you well wishes it
wasn't transcending in sales i just
needed to bow out while i had some
something left in me to bow out with i
was scared they were going to completely
take me down and have no chance of ever
coming back again the disaster's coming
i said it's here before and i've said it
to people many a time i truly truly
believe
the foundations of this country are
cracked
who is this country actually looking
after
because it don't feel like it's us
people are desperate
in england in 2022
who work full-time
and have always worked full-time
and they're desperate
it's it's actually disgusting
and he's like
there's no care
like where's the care gone from this
country
analysts say corporate insolvencies in
this region are up 30 percent this year
across the country they're up by nearly
a half the fear that companies wouldn't
survive rising costs and falling income
is now becoming a reality
we've been in touch with half a dozen
businesses who've gone under recently
who didn't want to speak publicly
because they say they feel ashamed
embarrassed one said it felt like a
failure but there was simply no way for
them to carry on
where demand is growing is places like
this the stores of free food donated to
those in need and that says abdul is a
growing number of people with full-time
jobs
since the original enhancement of the
energy prices going up there's just been
a huge demand
um and we're getting working-class
people coming in now there's
people just no benefits before uh but
we've got working-class we've got nurses
we've got quite a lot of people coming
in a lot of social workers coming in
because everyone's struggling it's
affecting everyone now
it's scary because a year ago i went
self-employed i was a teacher so i
worked from home a child minder
joe like most of us is making choices
she never had to think about before
it's always on my mind the fuel the cost
of fuel how many times i can boil the
kettle in the day it is literally always
on my mind and what i often do is i do
my shopping a week in advance
book my slot on my food shop and then
i'll go in the night before and cut out
anything that we don't definitely need
so any extras just get cut out
they are necessary choices being made by
millions of people and for a growing
number of businesses
impossible to survive greg milam sky
news bradford